Hace seis años,
descubrí algo que los científicos han querido saber desde hace tiempo.
¿Cómo captar la atención
de una sala llena de adolescentes aburridos?
Y parece que lo único que hay que hacer es mencionar la palabra pornografía.
(Risas)
Déjenme que les cuente cómo me di cuenta de esto por primera vez.
En 2012 yo estaba en un aula abarrotada de estudiantes de secundaria
que participaban en un programa extraescolar en Boston.
Mi trabajo, como oradora invitada del día,
consistía en motivarlos a creer lo emocionante que sería
tener una profesión en salud pública.
El problema era que,
cuando veía sus caras
podía notar en sus miradas que estaban en blanco,
simplemente estaban desconectados.
Ni siquiera importaba cómo estuviera yo vestida
que para mí era de lo más moderno.
Simplemente no captaba la atención de mi público.
Entonces uno de los dos adultos que trabajaba para el programa dijo:
"¿No estás realizando una investigación sobre pornografía?
Quizás puedes hablarles de esto".
De repente, esa aula de estudiantes de secundaria estalló
en carcajadas chocando los cinco entre sí.
Creo que también hubo algunos ruidos escandalosos.
Y todo eso porque alguien había dicho una palabra: "pornografía".
Ese momento resultó ser un momento decisivo
para mí y mi misión profesional de encontrar soluciones
para acabar con la violencia sexual en el noviazgo.
Hasta entonces yo había trabajado más de una década
en el problema aparentemente insoluble de la violencia en el noviazgo.
Los datos de los centros para el control y la prevención de enfermedades en EE.UU.
revelan que 1 de cada 5 estudiantes adolescentes de secundaria
sufre abusos físicos o sexuales
de su pareja cada año en EE.UU.
Eso significa que la violencia en el noviazgo es más frecuente
que el acoso escolar,
que el suicidio,
incluso que el fumar,
en esa misma población.
Pero resultaba difícil encontrar soluciones.
Trabajaba con un equipo de investigación
que buscaba nuevas respuestas a la pregunta:
¿Qué causa la violencia en el noviazgo, y cómo acabamos con ella?
Uno de los estudios de investigación que estábamos llevando a cabo
incluía unas preguntas sobre pornografía.
Nuestros hallazgos revelaron algo inesperado.
El 11 % de las adolescentes en la muestra
informaron que habían sido amenazadas u obligadas
a realizar actos sexuales
que el perpetrador había conocido por la pornografía.
Eso me intrigó.
¿Era la pornografía responsable de los datos sobre la violencia en el noviazgo?
O ¿era más bien una coincidencia que los consumidores de pornografía
fueran también más propensos a tener relaciones malsanas?
Investigué leyendo todo lo que pude
en la literatura especializada revisada por pares
y llevé a cabo mis propias investigaciones.
Quería saber
qué tipo de material sexualmente explícito veían los jóvenes,
con qué frecuencia y por qué,
para saber si podía descifrar
si era parte de la razón por la que, para muchos,
las relaciones sentimentales eran supuestamente malsanas.
Al leer, intenté tener la mente abierta,
a pesar de que muchos miembros del público
ya habían sacado conclusiones al respecto.
¿Por qué tenía la mente abierta en relación a la pornografía?
Bueno, soy científica social de profesión,
así que mi trabajo es ser objetiva.
Pero también tengo una visión positiva de la sexualidad.
Eso significa que apoyo plenamente el derecho
a tener cualquier tipo de relación sexual que se desee,
sin importar lo que implique,
a condición de que haya consentimiento entusiasta
de todas las personas implicadas.
Dicho esto, personalmente no estaba inclinada a ver pornografía.
Había visto algo, pero no era lo mío.
Como madre de dos hijos que pronto serán adolescentes,
tenía mis dudas
sobre cómo podría afectarles consumir pornografía.
Noté que, si bien mucha gente denunciaba la pornografía,
también había gente que la defendía firmemente
por diversas razones.
Entonces, en mi investigación académica,
realmente intenté despejar
si la pornografía era mala o buena.
Si era misógina o empoderadora.
No había una sola respuesta clara.
Había un estudio longitudinal que me preocupó mucho,
que mostraba que era más probable que los adolescentes que veían pornografía
perpetraran violencia sexual.
Pero el diseño del estudio
no llevó a conclusiones causales definitivas.
Otros estudios no hallaron
que el consumo de la pornografía por adolescentes
estuviera vinculado a determinados resultados negativos.
Sin embargo, otros estudios concluyeron que sí.
Al hablar con otros expertos,
me sentí muy presionada a elegir un bando referente a la pornografía.
Solo podía unirme a un equipo o al otro.
Incluso me dijeron que era débil de carácter
por no llegar a una conclusión concreta en cuanto a la pornografía.
Y fue complicado,
porque hay una industria
que está rentabilizando la fascinación del consumidor
por ver a las mujeres, en particular, no solo practicando sexo,
sino siendo amordazadas, ahogadas, abofeteadas,
cubiertas de saliva y de semen,
diciéndoles nombres degradantes muchas veces durante el sexo,
y sin saber siempre si han dado su consentimiento.
La mayoría de la gente aceptaría que enfrentamos un grave problema
de misoginia, violencia sexual y violación en este país;
y, probablemente, la pornografía no nos está ayudando.
Lo que me pareció un problema muy importante fue que
durante más de un siglo,
la posición contra la pornografía se había utilizado como excusa
para discriminar a los homosexuales
o a las personas que tienen fijaciones sexuales.
Así, por un lado, entendí por qué
nos preocupa mucho el mensaje que envía la pornografía,
y por otro lado, entendí
por qué nos preocupa mucho que se nos vaya de las manos enjuiciándola.
Durante los siguientes dos años,
investigué todas las afirmaciones alarmantes y horribles que pude encontrar
sobre la edad media de las personas que ven pornografía por primera vez,
y sobre la manera que afecta a su cerebro o a su sexualidad.
Esto es lo que encontré.
La pornografía gratuita en línea,
el tipo de pornografía que suelen ver los adolescentes,
es una terrible forma de educación sexual.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Pero ese no es su objetivo.
Es probable que no contamine sus mentes de manera instantánea
o que los convierta en consumidores compulsivos,
de la manera que algunos ideólogos nos quieren hacer creer.
Es rara la persona que no ve algo de pornografía en su juventud.
A la edad de 18 años,
un 93 % de universitarios y un 62 % de universitarias de primer año
habrán visto pornografía al menos una vez.
Y aunque a la gente le gusta decir
que Internet ha hecho que la pornografía sea omnipresente,
o que todos los jóvenes
con un teléfono inteligente definitivamente verán pornografía,
los datos no respaldan eso.
Un estudio a nivel nacional encontró que en el año 2000
un 16 % de los jóvenes de 10 a 13 años de edad
comunicaron que habían visto pornografía en el último año.
Y en 2010 esta cifra había aumentado.
Pero solo alcanzó un 30 %.
Así que no fueron todos.
Nuestros problemas respecto a los adolescentes y la violencia sexual
no solo se derivan de la pornografía.
De hecho, un estudio reciente
halló más probable que los jóvenes accedieran a imágenes sexualizadas
a través de otros tipos de material, más allá de la pornografía.
Piensen en todos esos videojuegos sexualizados,
programas de televisión, o videos musicales.
Puede ser que la exposición
a una corriente continua de material violento
esté causando nuestros problemas, con o sin las imágenes sexualizadas.
Al concentrarnos exclusivamente en los posibles daños de la pornografía,
puede que nos distraigamos y no veamos los problemas más importantes,
o que no descubramos las causas de la violencia sexual,
que son las verdaderas crisis de la salud pública.
Dicho esto, incluso mis propias investigaciones
demuestran que los adolescentes recurren a la pornografía
para informarse sobre el sexo.
Eso pasa porque no pueden encontrar
información fiable y objetiva en ningún otro lugar.
Menos del 50 % de los estados en EE. UU.
exige que la educación sexual se enseñe en las escuelas,
incluyendo cómo prevenir el sexo coercitivo.
Y menos de la mitad de esos estados
exige que la información presentada sea médicamente precisa.
Durante ese programa extraescolar en Boston,
esos niños tenían muchas ganas de hablar de sexo y de pornografía.
Y querían discutir todo eso
mucho más que discutir sobre la violencia sexual.
Entonces nos dimos cuenta
de que podíamos abordar los mismos temas de los que solemos hablar
con el pretexto de hablar sobre la educación de relaciones sanas,
por ejemplo, ¿cómo se define el consentimiento sexual?
O ¿cómo saben si lastiman a alguien durante el sexo?
O ¿qué límites saludables se deben poner al coquetear con alguien?
Podemos discutir todo esto
utilizando la pornografía como punto de partida
para nuestra conversación.
Es un poco como cuando los adultos dan a los niños
pasteles de chocolate como postre,
pero en secreto pusieron adentro un calabacín o algo sano.
(Risas)
Podemos hablar con los niños de lo sano, de lo que es bueno,
pero escondiéndolo en una conversación
sobre un tema del que creen que les gustaría hablar.
También descubrimos algo
que no necesariamente intentábamos explorar,
y que es que hay una manera fantástica de tener una conversación con jóvenes
sobre la pornografía.
Y eso es
asegurándonos de plantear esa conversación basada en la ciencia;
admitiendo cuánto entendemos los efectos de la pornografía;
hablando de los resultados desiguales
o de los puntos débiles de los estudios que se han realizado.
Debemos invitar a los adolescentes a ser consumidores críticos
de la literatura de investigación sobre la pornografía,
además de la pornografía misma.
Eso encaja bien con el desarrollo de los adolescentes.
A los adolescentes les gusta hacer preguntas
y les gusta que les animen a pensar por sí mismos.
Y nos dimos cuenta al comenzar a experimentar,
y dar lecciones sobre el consentimiento, el respeto y la pornografía,
que intentar obligar a los adolescentes a pensar de cierta manera
o forzarlos a escuchar un argumento unilateral sobre la pornografía
no solo es probablemente ineficaz,
sino que tampoco configura el tipo de comportamiento respetuoso y consensual
que queremos que aprendan.
Nuestro enfoque, lo que llamamos alfabetización pornográfica,
consiste en presentar la verdad acerca de la pornografía,
lo mejor posible,
teniendo en cuenta que hay un fundamento de evidencias en constante cambio.
Cuando la gente sabe
que impartimos un curso de nueva partes que dura 18 horas,
sobre alfabetización pornográfica a adolescentes,
creo que piensan que nos sentamos con los niños
y que intentamos mostrarles cómo ver la pornografía,
cosa que no hacemos,
o que somos parte de un grupo activista contra la pornografía
que intenta convencerlos de que si alguna vez ven pornografía,
va a ser extremadamente perjudicial para la salud.
Y eso no es todo.
Nuestro ingrediente secreto es que no emitimos juicios de valor.
No pensamos que la juventud deba o no ver pornografía.
Sino, sobre todo, queremos que sean pensadores críticos
siempre que la consuman.
Hemos aprendido,
de la demanda de nuestro currículo y formación,
a través de todo EE.UU y más allá,
que hay muchos padres y profesores
que tienen ganas de tener
conversaciones diferentes y realistas sobre pornografía con jóvenes.
Hemos recibido solicitudes de Utah, de Vermont,
de Alabama, hasta Hawái.
Durante ese programa extraescolar,
lo que vi es que desde el momento en que mencionamos la palabra pornografía,
esos niños estaban listos para discutir y debatir
con respecto sobre lo que querían y no querían ver en la pornografía,
y lo que querían hacer y no hacer practicando el sexo.
Además de discutir lo que era degradante para las mujeres
o injusto para los hombres o racista, todo.
Dieron unas opiniones muy sofisticadas.
Fue exactamente de lo que queríamos que hablaran
como activistas contra la violencia.
Como profesores, a veces salimos de la clase y pensamos,
"Es muy triste que ese chico en nuestra clase
piense que todas las mujeres llegan al orgasmo después del sexo anal".
En otras ocasiones, salimos de la clase y pensamos,
"Qué bueno que ese chico en nuestra clase que es homosexual,
dijera que ver la representación de su sexualidad en la pornografía
le salvó la vida".
O, "Esa chica en nuestra clase
que dijo que se sentía mucho mejor acerca de su cuerpo,
porque vio a alguien físicamente parecida a ella como objeto de deseo
en pornografía no extrema".
Aquí es donde me encuentro como activista contra la violencia.
Me encuentro investigando y hablando de pornografía.
Aunque sería más fácil
si en la vida las discusiones fueran unilaterales,
lo que he descubierto hablando con los jóvenes sobre pornografía
es que siguen interesados en estas conversaciones
porque permitimos que aborden cuestiones complejas.
Y porque somos honestos respecto a la ciencia.
Aunque estos adolescentes aún no son adultos,
están viviendo en un mundo adulto.
Y están preparados para mantener conversaciones adultas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)